There were once two sisters.
The older sister walked ahead of the younger one.
So the younger one always knew where to go.
How are you doing?
Cause your Gram and I have been a little worried about you.
My sister is dead.
There’s no more music in me.
No more dreams in me.
I’ve lost the one person on earth who understood me.
How’s school?
Bad as expected?
There’s a new boy in honor band.
(Music playing)
Hey!
You must be Lennie Walker.
Toby stopped by.
Go keep him company, make him feel welcome.
He is not interested in talking to me.
She was the love of his life.
No one at school gets it.
I don’t think it’s possible to get it
unless you’re in it.
Like we are.
Do you believe in signs?
The beyond?
I believe in everything.
Yes, by the way.
The heart breaks.
Music escapes.
That’s how it gets out.
(Music playing)
Joe Fontaine.
Toby Shaw.
I know I shouldn’t have come.
I just miss her so much.
We’re here
and without her.
Toby I can’t.
Hey. You’re okay. You’re okay. You’re okay.
And we’re gonna be okay.
(Music Playing)
What’s going on with you two?
Grief and love I don’t think we get one without the other.
With Joe I feel so very alive.
But when I’m with Toby there is someone with me in my grief.
I want to live like my sister did.
With daring, and spirit,
(Music playing)
and so much joy.